on perd une politique particulière il ne
me donnait pas d'argent de poche il
refuse à nous offrir des cd de musique
et vêtements des jeux vidéo ce n'est
même pas la peine de demander en
revanche pour les livres c'était budget
illimité pouvaient lui demander le livre
que je voulais même plusieurs livres peu
importe le prix ils paient sans discuter
bon en même temps ils n'étaient pas fous
ils savaient bien que je n'avais pas le
ruiner avec des livres de poche je me
souviens aussi que s'il me trouvais
devant la télévision ou devant
l'ordinateur il venait se placer devant
moi il me fixait jusqu'à ce que je
réagisse et il me disait li li est pas
complètement raison papa
[Musique]
lire c'est mal comment vous pouvez dire
ça du calme du calme je ne vais pas
essayer de vous convaincre de passer vos
journées sur netflix ou à jouer des jeux
vidéo ce que je vais faire c'est
critiquer la lecture tels que l'immense
majorité des gens la pratique et telle
que je la pratique est moi-même jusqu'il
ya encore quelques années je dirais 5 6
ans vous me voyez peut-être venir vous
dire que nous ne devons pas lire comme
nous lisons ce sera le moyen de
comprendre ce qu'est la bonne manière de
lire celle qui nous permet de tirer les
immenses bénéfices de la lecture oui
mais c'est quoi s et immenses bénéfices
bonnes questions j'y réponds et je vous
explique tout dans les prochaines
minutes ecoutez-moi attentivement
jusqu'au bout et non seulement vous
connaîtrez la vérité sur la lecture mais
en plus vous saurez quoi faire
concrètement pour tirer un immense
bénéfice de vos lectures
l'être humain a besoin de manger pour
vivre paraît-il à cet égard nous pouvons
dire qu'il est bon de manger puisque si
nous cessons de nous alimenter vous
hambourg ont cessé de s'alimenter
c'était d'ailleurs une méthode pour se
suicider dans l'antiquité une légende
raconte que pythagore aurait mis fin à
ses jours comme ça donc il faut manger
pour vivre d'accord mais cela signifie
t'il qu'il faut manger n'importe quoi
bien sûr que non l'évolution de l'être
humain a mis en évidence sur la très
longue durée ce qui est comestible c'est
à dire ce qui peut lui servir d'aliments
mais même parmi ce qui est comestible
nous n'avons pas intérêt à nous nourrir
de n'importe quoi oui nous avons besoin
de nous nourrir mais si vous prenez vos
trois opa quotidien chez mcdonald's ça
va mal se terminer c'est donc simple
certains aliments sont bons pour la
santé d'autres moins eh bien c'est la
même chose pour la lecture certains
livres ne sont pas un bon aliments pour
votre esprit je peux prendre un exemple
extrême est il bon de lire de la
propagande nazie à part si vous êtes un
historien professionnels qui travaillent
sur la propagande nazie la réponse est
non mais il y a plein de livres que l'on
peut comparer à de la malbouffe qui sont
un peu l'équivalent de netflix mais au
format écrit c'est par exemple le cas de
ce qu'on appelle la littérature de gare
c'est à dire les livres superficielle
qu'on peut lire facilement et rapidement
en attendant son train on peut comparer
ses livres comme la plupart des séries
netflix a de la malbouffe parce que leur
lecture est du pur divertissement
on lit pour passer le temps alors que
les bénéfices attendus de la lecture ce
qui est implicite dans les
encouragements des parents à leurs
enfants c'est que la lecture nous rend
plus intelligent à la fin du livre nous
comprenons mieux le monde nous
comprenons mieux notre existence donc
nous sommes capables de prendre de
meilleures décisions je simplifie parce
que la question des beignets de la
lecture et les plus complexes mais vous
avez compris l'idée lorsque mon père me
disait lily il oubliait comme l'immense
majorité des parents et comme tout le
monde en fait il oubliait la question
cruciale quoi lire pour répondre à cette
question il faut d'abord répondre à la
question pourquoi lisons-nous le
philosophe américain alan bloom donne
une réponse très claire dans son essai
l'âme des armées nous lisons pour mieux
comprendre le monde ou bien pour nous
divertir alors bien sûr en pratique les
deux finalités sur la plupart du temps
combinés on apprend toujours certaines
choses dans un ouvrage divertissants
comme un roman de gare et il peut y
avoir du divertissement dans un livre
qui explique le monde des anecdotes par
exemple mais ce qui est sûr c'est que si
vous voulez lire pour nourrir votre
esprit comme un aliment nourrit le corps
alors vous devez privilégier les livres
qui vous permettront de mieux comprendre
le monde ce genre de livre vous n'allez
pas les avaler en attendant votre train
à la gare mais à la fin de votre lecture
si vous avez bien lu et je vais vous en
dire davantage à ce propos dans les
prochaines minutes à la fin de votre
lecture si vous avez bien lu vous serez
un peu plus intelligent selon
schopenhauer seule une ultra minorité de
livres mérite que nous dépensions notre
précieux temps avec eux l'art de ne pas
lire et des plus importants pour lire le
bon il y à une condition c'est de ne pas
lire le mauvais car la vie est courte et
le temps et les forces sont limités on
ne peut jamais lire trop peu de mauvaise
chose et jamais assez ce qui est bon
je viens de vous parler de la cabine
mentation il faut préférer les bons
livres comme il faut préférer les bons
aliments d'accord mais il ya aussi la
question de la quantité les légumes et
les fruits sont bons pour la santé mais
si vous vous engagez votre corps réagira
probablement mal dans les faits vous ne
pourrez plus continuer d'ingérer des
légumes et des fruits au delà d'une
certaine quantité autre exemple à ma
connaissance un verre d'un bon vin de
temps en temps c'est bénéfique pour la
santé mais si vous enchaînez les verts
la balance bénéfice risque pour parler
comme les médecins la balance devient
négative est bien l'enjeu de la quantité
existe également pour l'alimentation
intellectuelle quel est précisément le
problème avec la lecture le problème
c'est que la capacité de digestion de
votre esprit comme celle de votre
estomac n'est pas illimité donc si vous
lisez trop même si je sais bien qu'à
notre époque c'est rarement le problème
mais bon si vous lisez trop vous
assimilez mal voire pas du tout que vous
avez lu vous aurez lu pour rien de votre
lecture vous ne sortirez pas plus
intelligent arc c'était quand même
l'objectif schopenhauer va même plus
loin de même qu'un excès de nourriture
gâte l'estomac et nuit à l'organisme
tout entier on peut aussi par un excès
de nourriture intellectuelle surchargé
et étouffer l'esprit bref à trop lire on
devient incapable de penser par soi même
on n'est plus capable que de répéter et
les pensées des autres sans les examiner
ni vérifier si elles sont pertinentes
par rapport à la question à laquelle on
réfléchit schopenhauer affirment eux
mêmes qu un grand nombre d'hommes
instruits sont paradoxalement des
imbéciles parce qu'ils ont lu trop de
livres effectivement j'en ai rencontré
des comme ça alors comment éviter de
devenir un obèse intellectuelle encore
une fois et je sais bien que c'est un
risque qui ne guette pas grand monde en
2022 mais je peux quand même vous donner
deux conseils précis le premier concerne
la durée quotidienne de lecture après
avoir lu beaucoup de biographies
d'écrivain et plus généralement
d'intellectuels je dirais que lire trois
quatre heures par jour c'est déjà très
bien ce sera d'autant plus suffisant si
vous suivez mon seconde conseil lisez
très attentivement en effet une heure de
lecture n'est pas égale à une heure de
lecture entre d'une part le lecteur qui
est omis de ses amis qui participent à
la conversation et qui réagit aux
notifications de son téléphone et
d'autre part le lecteur qui est seul
dans son canapé qui a mis son téléphone
en mode avion et qui a uniquement son
livre dans les mains entre ces deux
lecteurs il y à un monde il ne retire
pas le même bénéfice intellectuelle de
leurs heures de lecture si vous lisez
une seule heure chaque jour en étant
très concentré c'est déjà très bien donc
plutôt que de fantasmer comme moi je
lave ou plutôt que de rêver de lire
trois livres par jour soyons plus
concentrés pendant le peu de temps que
nous passons quotidiennement dans les
livres
si vous surveillez votre aliment si par
exemple vous manger de la salade bon eh
bien vous n'allez pas en manger de temps
en temps non vous devez manger de la
salade régulièrement presque chaque jour
disons 80% du temps pour en tirer les
dividendes en termes de santé mais avec
les livres vous ne pouvez pas faire ça
par exemple si je trouve que le monde
comme volonté et comme représentation de
schopenhauer est un bon aliment
intellectuelle tu ne devais pas le
relire chaque semaine plus énorme le
problème avec la lecture c'est donc que
nous oublions l'essentiel de ce que nous
lisons il ya plein d'idées intéressantes
dans le monde comme volonté et comme
représentation de schopenhauer mais
seule une minorité se fixeront dans ma
mémoire du coup est ce que ça valait le
coup de passer tant d'heures avec ce
livre dans les mains voici ce qu'en
pense le critique littéraire antoine
al-balah qui était un spécialiste du
style lire sans prendre de notes c'est
comme si on n'avait rien lui sait lire
comme tout le monde et c'est se
condamner à n'être jamais quelqu'un je
vais vous dire honnêtement ce que je
pense si vous lisez de bons livres sans
prendre de notes alors vous perdez 90 %
de votre temps je ne suis pas sur la fin
de ma vie mais j'ai déjà un énorme
regret j'ai lu comme un bourrin grosso
modo de 19 à 27 ans sans prendre de
notes résultat j'ai perdu un trésor
interdisez vous donc de lire un livre
intéressant sans prendre de notes le
minimum syndical c'est de souligner les
passages intéressants dans une liseuse
comme le kindle d'amazon puis de les
transférer sur votre ordinateur
je peux résumer mes trois arguments en
une seule phrase nous oublions ce que
nous avons mal lu dans de mauvais livres
vous avez toujours envie de lire non
mais je plaisante bien sûr et puis je
vous provoque pour vous faire réfléchir
la lecture est une activité très
profitable qui nous rend meilleurs à
condition de lire de bons livres dans de
bonnes conditions et surtout s'il vous
plaît prenez des notes voilà voilà
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu et
puisqu'elle vous sera utile si c'est le
cas donnez lui un pouce bleus et puis
laisser un commentaire pour améliorer le
référencement de la vidéo ce n'est pas
grand chose et ça m'aide vraiment je
suis romain j'étais avec mon fidèle
aristote et vous vous étiez sur mille de
culture générale appelée vous n'avez pas
besoin de vous prendre la tête pour vous
intéresser au meilleur de la pensée j'ai
une question à vous poser vous croyez
vraiment que les gens ont lu tous les
livres dont il parle bien sûr que non
sinon on ne pourrait pas parler grand
chose
et oui il y à 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'ya pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivés les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets savez vous avez lu
renan comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussit à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'ils les appliquent les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet ils brillent par
leur culture dans les conversations
c'est dans les débats et ils ont le
recul nécessaire pour faire preuve
d'esprit critique ça vous intéresse et
bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets et
je vous explique comment les appliquer
dès aujourd'hui pour vous cultivez 10
fois plus rapidement sans vous prendre
la tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit qu'ils ont sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo croyez moi
faites le et vous me remercierez